so now how I'm gonna prepare for my
podcast but how I'm gonna make sure that
the guests feel prepared and I know what
to expect so I now need to do my
research into how am I going to prepare
my guest on my podcast and some of these
people probably never been on a podcast
before and I've never hosted one so I
wanted to make sure that I was prepared
or I did the obviously some research
into it so I ended up in the same place
and that was Tim Ferriss his podcast
where the exact same episode and again
there was some there was two really
important things which I'm going to be
doing to make sure that I prepare my
guess appropriately and use these
techniques so the first thing is I'm
going to send the person that I'm going
to be getting on my podcast the very
first question that I'm going to ask why
do I do that
so I'm going to be doing that because
the guest could potentially come on the
podcast or anticipate the the
conversation and think Oh what is gonna
be the first question you might stump me
I'm not sure etc and that just takes
that away straight away so I'll be
sending them the actual question itself
the very first one so they can get a bit
of time in terms of what they want to
share what their answers are gonna be
and I'll probably do that a couple of
days before the actual podcast recording
and or a week before that the podcast
recording as well so that would be the
first thing I'll do and I think also
just to add to that is that it will
allow the conversation just go into a
natural flow because we'll go from one
question which they would have thought
about into the next question and so on
secondly before we actually do the
recording I'm going to give the person a
quick call so I'm gonna give them a call
and we're gonna have a bit of a chat
talk about what the first question is
gonna be again maybe discuss what
they're thinking about saying I'll say
do you know what you want to sort of
talk about yourself and the podcast and
anything you want to go through just
again just to make them feel a bit easy
just to encourage that sort of natural
state of conversation because that's
obviously what I'm gonna be aiming for
with the people that I get my shot I
don't want it to be sort of scripted or
anything like that so two things which
I'm going to be doing to prepare my
guests on my podcast is send them the
actual first question that I'm going to
ask a week or a couple of days before
the actual podcast and secondly give
them a quick call before we actually do
the recording and have a five-minute
conversation just to make them feel
relaxed and I was having a bit of a
conversation
[Music]